sexual hot tub water dangerous ocean
water and somewhere in between bathwater
warm like bathwater it's time for roses
and rose they hi you guys i'm lauren
zima
here with my own favorite brand of water
it's wine guys thank you so much for
being with us we are here again looking
at some of the best moments in bachelor
history on our most recent episode we
brought you the most Awkward kisses ever
ah and so this week we wanted to get
things a little hotter a little spicier
still a little awkward cuz it's the
bachelor but we are bringing you this
sexiest I wore a weird shirt for this is
it I'd look like I'm in prison but
elevated but then also one of our crew
guys thank you hos waste said it was a
little Parisian so maybe that's good for
some sexual vibes and I want to thank
Tameka in part for the idea for this
episode because she suggested on YouTube
that we do Peter's sexiest moments ever
well we're gonna start off for you
Tameka we have so much ground to cover
what do you want to cover it in the hot
tub was it our first moment is Peter and
Rachel in the hot tub Rachel Lindsey
season of The Bachelorette and we had
all been fawning over Peter for many
episodes and then we got this treat
they are sans clothing they're in the
hot tub they are kissing we are seeing
his hands go up her back we are
wondering why he's wearing that ring but
whatever it's Peter he can do whatever
he wants
ah when they came back everybody said
you've been gone a long time
well wouldn't you if you had Peter and
that you'd stay for a while would chef
so that moment was pure sexiness so
drink every time something is pure sex
[Music]
next we're throwing it back to
Bachelorette Season one Trista and Ryan
they were also in a hot tub but they
didn't get as wet as Peter and Rachel
did they just shared the most subtle
sexy slightly open mouth kiss and
afterwards she's like wow he's like ice
water about their chemistry and they're
still married today
so that sexiness turned into something
real and is it wonderful when a
connection is more than a connection
another hot tub moment Jordan you know
what drink every time I talk about hot
tubs Jourdan and Jojo in the hot tub
this was a sexy moment because these
people are just both so fit and hot and
like tan and quaffed and just perfect
and just dang dang there's something
very photographic about how beautiful
they are together moving on from hot
tubs we have another body of water that
serves for Bachelorette sexiness the
ocean we didn't love Courtney but Ben
did especially when they jumped into the
ocean together they just stripped right
down on that beach and went right in and
later in a memoir Courtney would reveal
the fate he had sex for just a few
seconds she said about 20 seconds in the
ocean she said and I quote just anyway
also in the ocean just drink every time
things get sexy in a body of water Juan
Pablo and Claire this was just
this was like giddy and that's what made
it sexy was the beginning of like love
and Claire called the ocean bathwater
and said what's sexier than bath the
feeling of bath water
how much more romantic can you get I'm
not sure if that is what I would call
super duper sexy no no baby draft born
but you know it's the bachelor you got
to have a little awkwardness in there
and they have those like wobbly legs so
drink every time something sexy but
awkward what's sexier to be in a hot tub
or the ocean bath water drink
responsibly Carly you're going to sit on
his lap awkward but sexy remember this
Chris soules and Carly on The Love Guru
date now they had to climb on top of
each other as this woman was instructing
them to breathe into each other when
Carly breathed out Chris is supposed to
breathe her in to use their hands they
could not kiss do you guys think it's
sexy to like do everything but kiss or
am i overestimating this it was weird I
don't do I hope they both add mints
their breath needed to be fresh to
breathe each other in but they
definitely explored what it was like to
do everything without doing anything and
there was something hot about that but
also sexy but awkward mm-hmm a similar
date because the bachelor loves to force
people to be physically close to each
other and you know really make those
connections happen how long have you
guys go Joe and chase remember this hot
no-good date it was hot again chase was
hot Joe Joe just had like hot guys on
her season didn't she you know I don't
know if I'd say that they all made for
great boyfriends and talked about Robby
but hot you know just physically
attractive so this was sexy and that's
it they were just both fit and sexy
and it wouldn't be a sexy countdown
without our favorite platinum vagine my
heart is gold on my vagine
it's platinum Corinne elympios everybody
she is multiple moments for herself
and learned how to say nah siesta
champagne Jumba
who could forget when on what I believe
was Nick viles first group date Corinne
took her bikini top off clingy bride
during a wedding themed photoshoot
making our moves then Corinne went for
classic sexy she put on a trench coat
and not much else even grabbing a can of
whipped cream to fulfill her fantasy
with Nick making it happen and last the
infamous or famous bikini bouncy house a
moment
Corinne straddle Nick she cuddled Nick
she swung around on Nick
okay she's kind of dope one more moment
involving water I don't know why it just
elevates things Ashley and JP this is a
throwback kissing in the rain they had
their glasses of wine next time he's
holding the umbrella over her it was
just cinematic you know a movie moment
and speaking of cinematic and I hate
that I have to do this because you guys
know how I feel about
he-who-must-not-be-named
[Music]
anyway but I gotta add to the list are
he kissing Emily Maynard on her season
of The Bachelorette against that brick
wall because he was a very film-like
kisser the way he grabbed her face the
way he put her up against the wall it
was movie worthy it was magical
again we know how it all turned out it's
weird isn't it - no now the future and
see how it affects how it sexy I find
things in the past much like one's own
relationships in rain you and me every
day you do something for me okay that
trip down memory lane is over our final
moments goes to a controversial one but
it has to be on the list because it was
a very real hookup can you guess what it
is
I'll give you five more seconds it is
Kaitlyn Bristowe and Nick Viall so Kate
letting it go on this dinner date and
she's like just acting like a normal
person in the normal world but you know
she is on a TV show so it's all being
filmed she said video and I go back yeah
yeah do you want to come back to my
hotel and mix like I absolutely do no
and they go back there then she's all
cute so I can't get the key card to work
and then they go in and all we get is
the audio
ah I don't actually know how sexy I find
that I just that moment sticks out to me
is such an iconic one in franchise
history
because the door closed and to just get
there's something about like we've had
moments on bachelor in paradise where
we've seen the night-vision cameras of
people like pulling a blanket over each
other that to me while it is much more
footage of the thing is not that sexy
versus this to just hear the audio to
just hear those noises what do you guys
think was that Caitlin and Nick moment
sexy or is it weird was it sexy then but
weird now was it ever sexy I think it
was sexy I think they had did they I
don't know anyway thank you guys so much
for joining us as we recap the bachelors
sexiest moments to take us home now I am
going to bring in roses and roses maker
of sexiest moments ever
JC everybody lean in for the kids
I know you actually like me
the Burt Reynolds the romance novel
cover
guys it's me my ears up it's a different
look for loving it I forgot to tell you
that next week we are going to go back
to bachelor news so we will be bringing
you the latest on coldest season Jordan
and Jenna and more and the week after
biggest bachelor behind-the-scenes
secrets so what two questions do you
have that you want to be answered tell
us what you want to know about behind
the scenes of the show and I'll tell you
everything you can you know I always
will
ok thanks bye excuse me you want to talk
about sexy speaking of sexy but awkward
remember that what's up Mike keeping it
sexy
let me quaff myself a little okay judge
it up trying to make something happen
oh god no my eyelashes are tangled
together what do we do Mike for this one
no voice in this guy
[Music]